my son will learn that I am NOT a dog
that can be cast aside when he tires of
me I shall take this sanctuary and from
the souls within compose a song of
screams and torment everyone it's Peter
Brown standing in for Daniel Starkey for
their review of total war Warhammer -
with the second installment in its total
war Warhammer trilogy developer Creative
Assembly has begun flexing its design
muscles battles are bigger and more
tightly animated scores of soldiers of
all different types sound impeccable and
the fineries of tactical and strategic
play are better than ever
[Applause]
we're the first entry kept a standard
Total War forum with an open-ended risk
inspired campaign of territory control
now there's a directive focus of vortex
you and a number of other armies across
the map will be racing to take control
of a seal which is put in place to
quarantine the forces of chaos your
target takes the form of a swirling
vortex comprised of magical energies and
through a premade set of special quests
you'll perform rituals that will in time
allow you to wrench control of the
vortex from everyone else but each time
you or your opposition performs one of
five successful rituals the pace of the
entire campaign will pick up a bit this
mode still balances total wars signature
dualistic design as you're worrying
about the stability of the vortex you
also need to manage cities and tax your
people they'll research new tactics
weapons and monsters and conduct
diplomatic consorts with the various
races of Warhammer rituals often take
some time to complete and in the interim
three of your most powerful cities will
be marked opposing factions will try to
sack and capture and raise any of them
and if you don't control all three by
the end of the ritual timer you've got
to try again and still deal with the
invaders that you attracted to your
lands as you progress through the
campaign the evil forces of chaos will
filter onto a map in a desperate attempt
to stop you during the late game they
become monstrously powerful to gauge how
well you've distributed your forces and
manage the challenges posed thus far and
they encourage you to seek help from
your neighbors as it's difficult to pull
together all the might you need all by
yourself and that brings up one of
Warhammer to is most engaging
consequences of the vortex rituals
progression yields huge impacts for
diplomacy encouraging you to forge
alliances with those outside of your own
faction this makes sense in play because
each groups broad goals are distinct
within the lore this confluence of goals
can lead to the creation of
Confederations which are a fancy name
for one of the most useful ways to build
out your empire like mines can over time
be persuaded to let themselves be
absorbed and this merges politics
economies research trees etc to give you
a quick sudden expansion of territory
often with the new Legion of eager
soldiers for your command this keeps the
game from chugging in the middle and
later stages where you'd have to take
back razed cities from Marauders only to
carry the dead weight of a developing
province for a while before seeing any
return the new system fits thematically
and boosts the importance of diplomatic
and factional ties on the map generally
you'll get along with your own groups
but you'll also find yourself stepping
into long-standing political alliances
many of which aren't always easy to
navigate speak briefly then remove your
file tank from the hallo we have in a
cold the focus of course is still in
battles but this system breaks up long
stretches of action with some careful
maneuvering from time to time as you
pick up more subjects and Commission
larger and larger armies you'll no doubt
unearth some of the other major new
additions to gameplay chokepoint maps
for instance give you a lot more to
consider in your approach to special
in-game locations some will funnel your
forces through a bridge while others
will use more different types of land to
give most bouts more depth the effect on
play with that alone is huge as it means
many powerful strategies aren't always
applicable at the same time you may find
that a holdout army of all cavalry can
repel a far stronger force in the right
conditions in time you'll learn where
these battlefields lie on the map that
in turn opens up countless other broad
scale strategies design a guide foes to
the points where you've got the
strongest defenses you could always do
this to a degree but the results are far
starker here on top of adding
much-needed variety to play
combined with the pacing changes that
the race to control the vortex brings
total war to war hammer feels fresh even
though you'll be stepping into the same
universe as last time I have the vortex
as the single-player mode is called
is among the best a campaign of this
type could be it encourages the right
amount of conflict to keep you moving
paces itself well if it's plenty of in
universe lore for die-hard fans and fine
tunes about every other facet of its
predecessor Plus as the game wears on
you can rest assure that there's a
definite clean ending every piece of
total war Warhammer 2 is designed to
force you to innovate and create new
plans on the fly which tests your
prowess over and over in new and
exciting ways in fact warrior 2
surpasses its predecessor in nearly
every respect everything that is except
the camera and multiplayer the complaint
here is simple and direct
there aren't enough factions for
competitive play at present you can only
use the four groups featured in the eye
of the vortex campaign dark elves high
elves Lizard Men and Skaven given that
the first game started with five races
for multiplayer and rapidly expanded
from there it feels like a big step
backwards to have so few options at the
moment not being able to pit vampires
against dinosaurs is a shame it need to
be cool to see how a elven dragons fare
against the mighty tours but that'll
have to wait there are some plan free
content expansions coming including a
massive campaign map that spans the
lands and races covered in both games
but that's still some time off those
fans who are put off by the monetization
of content in the first will likely have
the same complaints though they can rest
assure that the base game is still
pretty robust on its own but Warhammer
to total war doesn't reinvent anything
so much as it iterates on the ideas that
made the first so special
at its heart there's still the merit of
total wars big scale strategy and war
hammers precise tactical play but
through many tiny tweaks the developers
have refined the experience into one of
the most intriguing and exciting
strategy games ever made
[Music]
you